feeling tired all the time it's not just
you it's your brain paying a 40% tax
every time you multitask your brain
isn't a computer it's a on lane road
every time you switch tasks it takes 23
minutes to get back on track that's
longer than most Netflix episodes here's
the Pivot Point busyness is a shield
you're hiding behind endless emails and
pointless meetings feeling productive
while achieving nothing every urgent
task you fake prioritize it's a tax on
your future self
and your to-do list it's not helping
it's gaslighting you you spend hours
color coding tasks only to realize
you've done nothing that's because
motion is in progress It's just
reheating leftovers for your brain ready
to break the cycle start with the
2-minute surrender rule when stress
starts spiraling hit pause set a timer
for 120 seconds and do the thing it's
not about perfection it's about stopping
the Avalanche watch the full video to
learn how to reclaim your energy master
your focus
and stop the productivity Heist your
future self will thank you